[MUSIC PLAYING]
XERXES DOTIWALLA: Hi, I'm
Xerxes a developer advocate here
at Google, back again, in
our Adwords API series.
In this episode
we'll examine how
you can use the
API to make updates
to your AdWords accounts.
We'll look at a few
popular use cases,
and see how they serve
as a basis for almost
any kind of automation.
One of the most common
use cases of the API
is to pause and
resume ad groups.
For example you
could pause an Ad
when the inventory
for that item is
depleted, resulting in better
use of your advertising budget.
This highlights the power of
integrating your own systems
with the AdWords API.
So how would you actually
pause and resume an ad group?
Remember from the last video?
The code samples
are your friends.
You should have them
downloaded by now.
But if you don't, you
can grab them from here.
Again we'll be using
Java and Eclipse,
but the concepts are the
same for all the client
library languages.
Fire up Eclipse and
open updateadgroup.java.
We see our typical
boilerplate in main.
This time you'll notice that
main has a placeholder string
for the ID of the ad group.
Where would we get that ID ?
Well you could get
a programmatically
through the Get Method of the
ad group service interface.
One unofficial trick
that I use for testing
is to grab the ID from the URL
of the AdWords web interface
when viewing an ad group.
As usual the Run Example
method as the interesting code.
First it gets a reference to
the ad group service interface,
because it'll be making
an update to an ad group.
To update other
entities you would use
of their corresponding service.
A full list of available
services can be found here.
Then it creates a
new ad group object.
It sets the ID of the new
object to the ID of the ad group
that it wants to update.
Then it sets the
status to paused.
After that, it creates
an ad group operation
using our newly created ad
group object as the operand
and set as the operator.
Lastly, it calls the mutate
method of the ad group service
interface passing in the
ad group Operation Object.
So go ahead and replace the
placeholder with an ad group ID
from your test client account,
and try running the code.
After it runs log into the test
account and the web interface
and confirm the status
has been changed.
This same pattern is used for
most updates through the API.
So let's review it here.
Create a new object.
Set it's ID to be the ID of
the entity you want to modify.
Set the new value of the
property on that new object.
Create an Operation
Object with set
as the operator and this new
entity object as the operand.
And lastly, pass
the Operation Object
into the mutate method of
the appropriate service.
This is an update, so
we use the set operator.
Adds or removals would use
the Add or Remove operators.
If this seems
confusing, take a look
at other pieces of sample
code in this project.
You'll quickly see the pattern.
So now we know this
pattern, we can easily
make other updates as well.
Though many require more complex
objects than the ad group
status enum we used here.
For example another
popular use case
is to modify the bid for an
ad group programmatically.
The canonical example
is raising the bid
for an umbrella add
when it's raining.
Your app could consume
a weather web service
and then use the
average API to increase
the bid for this ad group.
You could modify this same
update ad group sample code
to make that kind of update.
Instead of setting
the ad group status,
you would set the
bidding strategy.
Click this link for details
on how to configure a bidding
strategy.
Another use case is
creating new campaigns.
In Eclipse take a look
at adcampaigns.java.
It's quite a bit of
code, but it follows
the pattern we just discussed.
In this case, once the
object hierarchy is created,
we use the add operator to add
a new budget via the budget
service and new campaigns
via the campaign service.
We don't need to
set the ID's here
because these are new entities
and don't have ID's yet.
So those are just a few examples
of updates using the API.
I said it before, and
I'll say it again,
I highly recommend you go
through the code samples
as they really are the
best way to learn this API.
We have accomplished a lot
in these last five videos.
You made your first API
call, retrieved reports,
and got a taste of automation.
Of course, there's additional
API functionality to learn.
These guides will definitely
help you along the way.
Now you're ready to start
building your own real AdWords
API application.
And once it's up
and running, you'll
see increased
operating efficiency
through automation
and greater visibility
through custom report.
Thanks so much for being with
us through these initial steps.
And keep an eye out
for more AdWords API
videos on the Google
Developers channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]